we should acknowledge that Carson
appears in that video to place himself
between the crazy guy and his girlfriend
potentially saving her life in the
process and that takes real courage so
it's not for the sake of loading
obviously that we point out that Carson
was not only a far-left activist but
according to reporting from Andy no was
a self-described antifa member and his
girlfriend no reports had previously
posted anti-cop sentiments writing that
uh the police do not protect you along
with aab and BLM now the details are
relevant not because we want to dunk
over a dead body but because there are
very important lessons that must be
learned in order to prevent this sort of
thing from happening in the future you
don't walk in the city at 4:00 a.m. and
you don't take public transportation in
the city at 4:00 a.m. everything is more
dangerous after dark in the city and
every person you encounter has a greater
likelihood of doing you harm that's not
paranoia it's just the reality so
mistake number one was being there in
the first place